[Music]
so let's go to uh ann in
los angeles what's up anne
hey dr john
i want to start by saying thank you for
all that you do um i actually do think
you have the greatest mental health
podcast in the world yeah so i think
you're awesome and i appreciate the work
that you're doing for people mom is this
you
just kidding thank you ann thank you
run go do your laundry
that would be my wife who actually said
those exact words today all right so
what's up man how are we doing
uh well i've i've had better days i'm
not doing great if i'm being honest but
i have a kind of a two-part
yeah thank you i've got a two-part
question um
how can i care for myself and shield my
children from major trauma while
choosing to remain in a marriage with my
sex addict husband
and then also what more can i do to
support him my husband's recovery
without further neglecting myself and my
needs
oh
man
so tell me about the sex addiction
yeah so
we've been married for eight years we
have two kids they're ages four and five
two boys
and he has struggled with the sex
addiction and intimacy disorders since
well before i met him um he's intimacy
avoidant with me um you know acts out
regularly with
ex-girlfriends former affair partners
sex workers you name it a lot of online
infidelity emotional infidelity and
physical infidelity
he does have significant childhood
trauma childhood sexual trauma tragic
loss of his father at a very young age i
also have significant childhood trauma
which i'm sure doesn't help the
situation at all i'm a big old seven on
the aces um score but my husband has
really short periods of sobriety um
followed by a relapse every like year to
18 months on average
he's in and out of therapy with his csat
a certified sex addiction therapist
and currently not in therapy display to
relapse about six weeks ago
um and i'm just living my life in a
constant state of hyper vigilance uh i
have severe ptsd nightmares panic
attacks
triggering episodes
what's happening hold on it's happening
right now take a breath take a breath
take a big deep breath and hold it for a
second okay
and let it out
so
so really i'm just trying to navigate um
you know how to
be a mom to my two kids be a um
devoted and supportive wife and walking
alongside him and his um
his journey of recovery because he's
he's not a bad person he's a really
traumatized person and he
you know has uses there his his coping
mechanism is unfortunately a sex
addiction which is extremely
traumatizing for a relationship
um okay so let me let me up here let me
hop in here okay what happened here
i
am gonna
do a couple of things here
i'm gonna tell you some hard truths is
that fair is that cool
yeah
and i'm gonna say some things that i
know the internets are not gonna like
is that cool
sure yes okay
um and you can
take what i'm gonna say
and say that guy's an idiot he's full
he's a [ __ ] or
you can
sit with it for a season okay
but what i'm gonna say is heart
the first thing is
your husband's childhood trauma is very
very real
so is yours
seven on the aces score is astounding
that's really high yeah
and
he has a choice
and so far
he has chosen
to not be about healing
he has chosen
to continue a series of destructive
behaviors that are blowing up his life
multiple other women's lives and most
importantly the one woman
he said was going to be his one woman
oh but and two little boys who are
growing up looking at this
play-by-play saying this is what being a
man looks like this is what being a
caring loving husband looks like this is
what being a caring loving father looks
like
so
when you talk about trauma the language
you use
is a very common narrative in our
culture right now which is if this stuff
happened to you you are
you are de facto broken
as though you got in a car wreck
and you smash the bumper and that
bumper's always gonna look like that
and i am telling you that that is false
it's a hundred percent wrong
and where i know this is gonna be hard
the way i'm saying this and and i
apologize but i don't apologize okay
it's really easy for you
to lump into to fall into that
to take his behaviors
and say but it's because of
because if you don't you have to look in
the mirror and say my husband is
continuing to choose other women over me
despite how much it hurts me
he's continuing to abandon his kids
emotionally and um
just his whole his whole
parental
in every way possible
and so it's actually it's a it's a
soothing force it's a it's a lotion it's
a bomb to say but it's because of this
and so i need you to hear me say across
all addictions
there is no relational healing when some
with an addict
until the attic gets clean
it doesn't exist
so if somebody comes into a therapy
session and they're drunk they have to
leave or they're an alcohol they have to
leave until and get clean and then they
can go do the work
but right now your husband's choosing to
remain connected to his addiction
not get well and heal
and so ultimately you can't control him
you can only control you
and i say this very very rarely
but you need to have a hard look at the
at the ecosystem you're raising those
boys in and you have to have a hard look
at your marriage
yeah
is that fair
yes
is your childhood trauma
one of
neglect and abandonment or fixing
absolutely yeah okay
so this whole thing feeds a narrative
that your body knows it feeds a story
that your body
has been down before right and so part
of you getting out of this thing is you
deciding to get well
yes is that fair
absolutely yeah
i'm so i'm heartbroken for you
and you could probably hear my voice i'm
mad at him i've never met him and
as a rule i don't get mad at addicts i
get heartbroken about addicts
um
this one feels different to me
this one feels something feels off about
this
um
and i'm just i'm just frustrated for you
i'm heartbroken for you i'm mad for you
all those things
i can hear it but i think that's that's
one of the things i struggle with is
when i do approach a conversation with
uh some professionals or in the times
that i've tried to share with friends or
the very few family that i have because
i'm mostly estranged from my family um
i've i've lost support systems because
of
um
an attitude of
he's just a jerk a sex addiction isn't a
real thing and then when i you know when
i work with his
his um his actual sex education
therapist and i learn and educate myself
on the cycles and and
i i
i see it differently but i find myself
isolating um because i is such a
um
misunderstood
um
conditions not the right word but
misunderstood addiction that
i'm finding myself just completely
isolated because talking about it brings
more shame for me but also the fear of
pushing people away or or
people having an image of our family and
and of him you know i want to protect
him too which i should probably
shouldn't care so much about that but
well but but you love him but here
here's the thing of course yeah
addiction just like other other issues
that we talk about here on the show a
lot
the addiction
is a context not an excuse
right you are being abused
your boys are being abused
okay and he has an addiction
those two things are one does not cancel
the other out and one does not make the
other okay
but they can run simultaneously
so what that means is i might have to
leave this marriage but i'm not gonna
shoot him
i might have to leave this marriage but
i'm not going to
be bitter and raged out
i'm going to be heartbroken you see what
i'm saying like the resulting action may
be the same
how we
maybe we're going to parse out there's a
difference between being a jerk and
being someone who struggles with
addiction great
i still have to make sure that i'm well
and okay
and right now you're not
right and you deserve more than that
and yes your friends are knuckleheads
sexual addiction is very very real
and
i've been with not all there's some
extraordinary ones
but i've heard from addiction counselors
that once they classify you with an
addiction
it excuses all other behaviors and
everyone around you just has to tolerate
it all and that's nonsense too
yeah there comes a moment when somebody
is an addict
and they are hurting you let's just use
meth you're addicted to methamphetamines
and they keep coming home and they steal
from you and they are scary to be around
and they're up for four days and there's
holes in their face and there's holes in
the drywall and the kids are terrified
there's a moment when i say i love you
and
you cannot be here
you see what i'm saying
yes and so those are your i don't want
you to lump all like addiction is not a
free pass on your safety and addiction
is not a free pass on the example your
boys are getting
right and you're gonna have to really
reckon with
this this marriage was gonna be the
thing that fixed you
your body is gonna feel this what's
happening right now if you choose to
leave this marriage your body's gonna
feel that as a
major trauma because it's going to be a
trauma on top one is that fair
absolutely yeah okay yeah i think that's
why i'm avoiding that exactly i almost i
would almost be willing to guarantee it
and i've just met you like three minutes
ago yeah but yes i would almost
guarantee it there's layers to this this
hurt for you
the question that you have to ask
yourself is what are you gonna do
and if you've made peace my husband just
sleeps with everybody ex-girlfriends
neighbors
sex workers whomever
that's who he is
if you make peace with it then make
peace with it and stop going to war
if you're not
then you have to own reality you have to
acknowledge the truth here which is he
has chosen to not get well for eight
years
he's chosen to not abstain from the
thing that is killing him that is
killing his wife then now it's going to
hurt his kids
and the question is what are you going
to do
right
yes and listen
please know you're not by yourself in
this i am heartbroken with you
it's my opinion that sex addiction is
one of the hardest addictions to clear
because it's so deeply woven into a a
need right a huge connection it's so
prevalent in society too you know the
internet has made things i think a lot
worse for abs absolutely
it's a mess alcohol you can remove it
from a household you can't take the
internet away from the world you can't
take pretty women off the streets you
can't you know it's it's everywhere it's
like being addicted to water right or
it's like having disordered eating
challenges like you've got to make peace
with food because you can't just stop
eating forever you can stop cocaine
forever you can't stop it right so very
very similar here and you can't be
married and just avoid sex the rest of
your life too because you right intimacy
is a cornerstone of a marriage right so
all that to say is
is a mess
there is healing i've seen it i've met
those people there's healing
um
his decision to go sleep with other
people is not a reflection of you
your inability to quote unquote fix him
does not mean you're failing
okay uh yeah i think on a cerebral level
i understand that intellectually um and
then emotionally uh
you know processing it and then really
accepting that is a little harder it is
i want you to this is gonna be hard
and maybe spend some time with your
counselor writing this stuff down but
you haven't been on a 10-year failed
journey to fix some dude
and his desi
his choice to not be intimate with you
and to
not
truly try to get to the bottom of his
um
addiction
it's not because you weren't pretty
enough
or because you weren't sexy enough
or because you didn't do the right
things or say the right things or walk
the right way
he's got stuff in his heart and his head
and his experiences that are heavy and
hard no question about it
but that's not a context for abuse
that's not a context for hurting you
it's not a con that's not a it's a
context not an excuse for abuse it's not
an excuse to hurt you and it's not an
excuse
to drag two little boys through this is
what manhood looks like and this is what
fathering and husbanding looks like
i'm so sorry
it was one of those calls i wish there
was like some great
magic dust i could sprinkle on this one
this one's a mess this one's gonna be
hard it's gonna be tough to unwind
you're gonna have to get a professional
to walk with you
please do that because you
are worth
more